-Our next guest is an
Academy Award-winning actor
you know from iconic films like
"Thelma & Louise,
"A League of Their Own,"
and "Beetlejuice."
She's also the founder
and chair of the
Geena Davis Institute
on Gender in Media.
Her memoir,
"Dying of Politeness,"
is out now.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend Geena Davis,
everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hi, Geena.
I'm so happy to have you here.
-I'm so happy to be here.
Thank you.
-We ran into each other at
the Emmys, which was lovely.
-Yes, yes.
-But you got one selfie
from the Emmys,
and I want to point out,
it was not with me.
And I also saw Lizzo.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I feel like
I blew my opportunity
to get a selfie with her.
You even gave her
a shout-out onstage.
-Well, that's why
she wanted a selfie.
-Okay, got it.
-Because I gave her a shout-out.
No, well, yeah, because she --
Her award was right before me,
and she was talking about
the same kinds of stuff
that I got the award for.
-Which was about representation.
And, you know, again,
you talk --
Your whole institution is
about, you know,
gender in media
and representation.
And it's actually
very fitting to have you here
the same night as
the vice president,
because you played
the president on television.
-Oh, right. That's right.
-Fictional you,
one step above the old...
-You know, I didn't say
anything about that
when I met her backstage.
-That's very cool.
That's very...
But you were on a show called
"Commander in Chief,"
and this was only on
for one season,
but it did -- it did
make a difference.
-It did.
A survey was done after
the show went off the air
and found that people were 58%
more likely to vote for
a female candidate for president
after seeing me
behind the desk only 19 times.
-Yeah.
-So...
-I mean, imagine if it had
been on a second season.
-I would -- I would
be the president by now.
-Congratulations on your book.
-Thank you.
-I heard that you kept
index cards for both book ideas,
remembering things,
but also inventions.
You've come up with
some ideas for inventions.
-I -- Yeah. I can't help it.
I just constantly come up
with ideas for stupid things.
When I was shooting archery,
I would tell my coach excitedly,
you know, "I came up with this
great thing that archers need."
And he said, "Oh, that's great.
You'll make tens of dollars."
-Well, you have -- Can you share
your fish-tank idea?
-Yes, yes.
So, it's --
It would be home snorkeling.
-Yeah.
-And, so, if you had
a very large fish tank
and it has
a gasket on the bottom
so you can poke your head up
and put your mask on,
and then snorkel
in your own fish tank.
-Gotcha. So, from the neck up,
you'd be snorkeling?
-Yes.
-Wow.
-Who said you need your body
to be snorkeling?
-Yeah, no one ever said
one way or the other.
Yeah, I mean --
-Right.
-I do -- If you ever are
looking for investors,
please make sure I don't
accidentally give you money.
[ Laughter ]
-Rats!
-So, the title
"Dying of Politeness"
is based on a story
from your youth.
-Yes, yes. When I literally
almost died of politeness.
When I was about 8 or so,
my parents and I
went out to dinner with
my great-uncle And great-aunt.
And Uncle Jack was
driving us back to his house,
who's 99 years old.
And, so, it was
a quiet little street,
but he kind of veered in
the oncoming lane and back.
And my parents realized
this was going on.
And I was sitting
right behind him,
and they put me in between them
because I would die
a little less.
Forget about that I had
a straight shot
through the windshield.
So, finally,
he veers over there,
and there's nowhere to --
It's a two-lane road.
And he stays
straddling the line.
And a car is coming,
and we're going to be killed.
And we're gonna have
a head-on collision.
And my parents say nothing.
And we're a millisecond
away from, you know,
having this accident, and,
finally, my great-aunt says,
"A little to the right, Jack."
He goes a little to the right,
and then I see the faces --
The people are passing by
about a foot away,
and I see their
horrified faces streaking past.
-But this was your parents
would rather die of politeness
than say anything to Uncle Jack.
-Well, you know,
later that I realized
we were gonna --
They were willing to die --
literally die --
rather than say something.
I mean, but they could have
politely also said,
"A little to the right, Jack,"
instead of, "Holy God,
you're gonna kill us all.
"Pull over.
Let me drive," you know?
Where was "protect the child"
part? Yeah.
-Well, it's very damning of
that style of back-seat driving.
-Right, right, right.
-You talk about
"Thelma & Louise"
and also that you were
in this sort of brief moment
where people thought,
from "Thelma & Louise" and from
"A League of Their Own,"
that it was
the beginning of a movement,
that, all of a sudden,
there would be these
female-driven dramas,
female-driven comedies,
and then it
kind of didn't happen.
-Did not happen. Right.
And female sports movies --
that was the big thing.
Because, yeah,
they're always a big hit.
And, yeah, both of those movies,
the press announced,
"This will now
change everything."
And waiting for that.
And I'm in two movies
that changed everything.
And maybe
five years or so later,
"First Wives Club" comes out.
-Yeah.
-And that was a big hit.
And "Okay, now this one will
change everything."
And so every, you know,
five-or-so years,
something comes along that
again doesn't change everything.
-I think it's always a mistake
to think one is
an indicator of a pattern.
-Exactly, exactly.
-Yeah.
-To be on, like,
"People" magazine cover,
it has to have happened
three times.
-Yeah.
-Because then it's --
Yeah, now it's a thing.
-Then it's an actual thing.
-Then it's a thing.
-You are an Oscar winner,
and, yet, by this photo,
one of your Oscars
had a bit of a mishap.
-Yes.
-Before I show this photo,
what happened?
-So, it was the
'92 earthquake in California,
and it fell off the mantel
and got dented.
And I asked them,
could they repair it,
and then they said "No,
we'll give you a different one."
"No, no, no.
I'll keep the real one."
-See if you can guess
which one fell.
What I like about it is,
you could also say
this one's bent or this one
has really bad B.O.
-Oh!
-Yeah.
-That's good.
-This one is opting out of where
you put him on the mantel.
-"Dude."
Congratulations on the book,
and thank you so much
for being here with us again.
It's always such a pleasure.
-Thank you.
-Geena Davis, everybody.
"Dying of Politeness"
is available now.
We'll be back with more
"Late Night."